j'ai décidé de me présenter devant vous
de mettre mon destin entre vos mains
pour le salut de la france
il y a toujours eu chez eric zemmour une
rhétorique de l'homme providentiel
[Musique]
bien évidemment ce qui était frappant
dès le début de ce discours c'est
d'assumer le choix du lieu on voit bien
qu'il a essayé six d'attraper
l'électorat qui était celui de françois
fillon en 2010 est à la fois par le lieu
et par les monts et quand eric zemmour
dit cette fois ci on ne volera pas
l'élection c'est un clin d'oeil évident
aux électeurs de françois fillon j'ai
choisi le trocadéro pour venir laver les
affronts de la droite les affronts du
peuple qui a le sentiment légitime
on lui a trop longtemps volé son vote
j'ai choisi le trocadéro en pensant au
maréchal foch sublime vainqueur de la
terrible guerre de 14 18 qui nous
regarde du haut de sa statue cet après
midi il revendique l'idée de nostalgie
est d'ailleurs tout son discours
fonctionne aussi sur une forme de france
sépia de france d'antan vous le savez
mieux que quiconque la crainte de la fin
de la france n'est pas une crainte
abstraite ce n'est pas un truc d'intello
ce n'est pas une lubie nostalgique la
crainte de la fin de la france c'est le
malheur indéfinissable de se sentir
étranger dans son propre pays
c'est l'angoissé de vivre dans un pays
violent c'est l'horreur devant les
victimes qui se multiplient c'est le
désespoir devant une classe politique
s'il h n'ayez pas peur de vos
convictions ce que vous pensez vous
n'êtes pas les seuls à le penser
une majorité de français le france je
suis là pour lutter contre la fatalité
en rhétorique on se dit que les concepts
mobilisateur sont plutôt des éléments
favorables c'est la croissance l'espoir
le renouveau et là ils jouent sur la
peur en disant que la peur est quelque
chose de naturel et qu' il est le seul à
pouvoir la combattre
[Musique]
nous sommes nous sommes les seuls
héritiers d'une droite qui aiment la
france j'aurais besoin des gaullistes
j'aurai besoin des souverainistes
j'aurai besoin de toutes les familles de
la droite et de tous les patriotes et
des amis aux républicains et je les
accueillerai j'ai des amis au
rassemblement national ils auront toute
leur place à mes côtés faites-vous
partie de cette bataille historique
allons-nous décider de notre avenir
allons nous donner tous à la france oui
tout donner parce que rien ni personne
ne nous empêchera décrire le destin de
notre pays c'est ce qu'on appelle la
parole performative c'est à dire que par
ma parole à moi eric zemmour je peux
changer le et évidemment il en a usé
dans ce mythique parce que l'élection
présidentielle est une façon de confier
le pouvoir à un homme et donc il a
d'abord parlé de lui beaucoup parce que
je n'ai pas passer ma vie à trahir mes
promesses je n'ai pas passer ma vie à
intriguer je n'ai pas passer ma vie à
vivre d'argent public ma vie je les
passais à vous défendre j'ai passé ma
vie à dire la vérité et en payer le prix
et aussi il a beaucoup dit je veux je
veux il ya une scansion de je veux je
suis le rempart contre le fatalisme donc
en réalité il y à l'idée de ce qu'on
appelle en rhétorique le saut au dilemme
où le tiers exclu c'est à dire moi ou le
chaos est donc en noircissant l'autre
branche de l'alternative je valorise par
contre à ce que je propose moi et il n'y
aurait rien d'autre que moi ou le déluge
moi ou le naufrage mois où la fin de la
france et donc il se présente comme le
seul possible sauveur de la france je
suis le seul candidat de droite de cette
élection regardez les
valérie pécresse est une centriste
marine le pen est une socialiste en
économie quant à emmanuel macron il a
passé dix ans au pouvoir depuis trente
ans hollande et il ne s'est toujours pas
de quel bord il est la rhétorique d'eric
zemmour est une rhétorique
catastrophiste pour par contraste
évidemment valoriser son programme et se
définir comme un homme providentiel
donc c'est vrai que il use et ils
abusent de formules très noir pour par
contraste appelé les gens à voter pour
lui comme une sorte d'ultime possibilité
de sauver la france on dit de moi que je
suis dur parce que les souffrances de
mon peuple man durcissent on dit de moi
que je suis dur parce qu'à nice j'ai
rencontré patrick jardin il ya quelque
chose qui était frappant dans ce
discours également s'était l'appel à des
faits divers et à des personnes qui ont
vécu des drames c'est à dire l'idée du
storytelling l'idée d'appuyer son
programme sur des faits patrick jardin a
perdu sa fille nathalie assassiné le
soir du bataclan on a enlevé à cette
femme son mari qui était chauffeur de
bus à bayonne laissé pour mort par une
bande de racailles ça induit une notion
de réussie et donc de concret et donc en
s'appuyant sur le réel eh bien ils
convoquent des faits qui sont vrais pour
appuyer un programme avec l'idée que par
capillarité la vérité du fait divers a
soit la vérité du programme lui-même
c'est quelque chose que faisait dans une
toute autre ambiance barack obama qui
parlait de gens qu'il avait rencontré au
cours de la campagne pour asseoir son
programme cette de valorisation du
storytelling est intéressante parce
qu'elle permet de donner du concret à un
discours programmatique
[Musique]